Kasey is autistic, and she says it's puzzling, neurotypical people and how much they lie. And she's not alone.
Kasey是自闭症患者，她说神经典型（普通）人非常让人费解，他们撒谎的频率太高了。而且她并不是个例。
Yeah. In our support groups, that issue comes up a lot. For some people, it's very puzzling, and they just don't understand the concept. And especially because so often, lies are just completely transparent.
是的。在我们的互助小组中，这个问题经常被提及。对一些人来说，这非常令人困惑，他们根本无法理解这个概念。尤其是当谎言往往非常直白易拆穿时。
She gave me this example. When she worked in HR, they caught this guy who was having an inappropriate relationship with his administrative assistant. A naked picture of her was on his work computer. And still, he denied it, kept lying.
她给我举过一个例子。她在人力资源部工作时，发现有个男同事和他的一名行政助理有不正当关系。他的办公电脑里甚至还有一张那个女人的裸照。但他依然予以否认，坚持撒谎。
It's just baffling to me. It's just-- it's inexplicable. I don't understand the continuing in the lie. And I don't understand why they haven't learned at an earlier point that it's not productive, that this is not an effective tool for you.
这让我感到极其费解。这简直——简直不可理喻。我不明白为什么要坚持撒谎。我也不明白为什么他们没能早点意识到这种做法毫无意义，意识到这根本不是一个有效的沟通工具。
Looking around on Reddit, we found a lot of autistic people writing about this exact thing. Here's somebody who posted saying, "I recently realized that a lot of things I had always categorized as lies are not seen that way by NT people--" neurotypical people.
在Reddit上闲逛时，我们发现很多自闭症患者都在讨论这件事。有人发帖说：“我最近才意识到，很多我一直归类为‘谎言’的事情，在神经典型人看来并非如此——”也就是普通人。
"Like, they say it, knowing it isn't literally true, but they don't think of it as a lie because they don't expect others to believe it. For example, here are some things that I always thought were weird, inexplicable lies--" and then there's a list. "It was great to see you. Let's do this again soon. I hope you have a great holiday. You are so funny. I love your hairdo. Where did you buy that dress? I need to get one, too. Oh, wow, that's very interesting. See you later."
“比如，他们说出来的时候，明知那不是字面事实，但他们并不认为那是谎言，因为他们根本没指望别人会信。例如，以下是我一直觉得奇怪且莫名其妙的谎言——”接着是一个清单。“见到你很高兴。咱们很快再聚。希望你假期愉快。你太风趣了。我很喜欢你的发型。你在哪买的裙子？我也得买一件。噢，哇，这太有意思了。回见。”
They continue-- "I've decided to start translating a lot of NT chatter from its literal meaning into a simple form of, 'Hello, I want you to see me as friendly so I am making friendly noises.'"
他们继续写道：“我决定开始把很多神经典型人的闲聊从字面意义翻译成一种简单的表达，即：‘你好，我想让你觉得我友好，所以我正在发出友好的声音。’”
Do--
你——
Yes. [LAUGHS]
是的。[笑]
Do you relate?
你有同感吗？
I do. The white lies and the polite fictions and the pleasantries that go along with small talk, a lot of autistic people really do perceive that as lying. For me, I recognize that it's a cultural structure, rather than an intent to deceive.
我有。很多自闭症患者确实把客套话、礼貌性的虚构和寒暄视为撒谎。对我来说，我意识到这是一种文化结构，而不是为了欺骗。
And does that make it any better?
那这会让情况好一点吗？
Absolutely.
当然。
She remembers when she realized just how widespread lying is for neurotypical people. She was a teenager, and she says she was heavyset, from a heavyset family.
她记得自己意识到神经典型人的谎言有多么普遍的那一刻。当时她还是个十几岁的少女，她说自己长得比较胖，一家人都比较胖。
That's pretty normal to me. I am not offended by or afraid of the word "fat." But a lot of the people that were my friends were very afraid of that word. And so they would say to me, oh, you're not fat. And for me, that was just baffling.
这对我来说很正常。我不觉得“胖”这个词有什么冒犯性，也不怕这个词。但我很多朋友非常害怕这个词。所以她们会跟我说，噢，你不胖。对我来说，这简直让人困惑。
I understood that they were trying to be kind, but I couldn't fathom how they thought that would actually be believed or helpful. I mean, it's a demonstrable fact. [LAUGHS] I have a mirror. I know what I look like. It started to make me clue in to this idea of white lies and polite fiction.
我明白她们是想表现得友善，但我无法理解她们怎么会认为这种谎话真的能让人相信，或者会有所帮助。我是说，这分明是显而易见的事实。[笑]我有镜子。我知道自己长什么样。这让我开始留意到这种“善意的谎言”和“礼貌性的虚构”的概念。
And then with the teenage politics, you start to see people who-- oh, I'm so happy to see you. Awesome. Let's hang out. And then behind the person's back-- oh, my god, I can't stand her. She is just the worst. So I started to catch on that this was not just widespread, but that this was considered appropriate behavior.
然后到了青春期的各种交际，你开始看到人们——噢，见到你太高兴了。太棒了。咱们常聚啊。然后转过身背地里却说——天哪，我简直受不了她。她真是差劲透了。所以我开始明白，这不仅是普遍现象，而且被视为一种恰当的行为。
Now, of course she's used to it. When I talked to her, she was just about to go to a conference where she knew people who barely remember her, who'd be saying, so great to see you, and not mean a word of it. And she's OK with that. She ignores it, moves on. But she tries to keep things more strictly truthful.
当然，现在她已经习以为常了。我采访她时，她正准备去参加一个会议，她知道那里有人甚至记不清她的名字，却还是会说“很高兴见到你”，完全是言不由衷。她对此没意见。她选择无视并继续前行。但她努力保持更加严谨的诚实。
So you never lie?
所以你从不撒谎？
I won't say never. I think of myself as sort of practicing radical honesty with tact. So I do my best to tell the truth in all circumstances.
我不会说“从不”。我觉得自己是在实践某种“讲究策略的彻底诚实”。所以我尽我所能，在任何情况下都说真话。
I have to say, if that's your philosophy, I find it so interesting to think about, what are the very few examples where you do let yourself lie, where you feel like that's the right thing to do? What are those?
我得说，如果这是你的准则，我发现思考这些问题很有意思：有哪些极少数的情况是你允许自己撒谎的？你觉得那是正确的做法？那是些什么情况？
So from a moral and scriptural basis, one is justified to lie to protect others from individuals who mean to do them harm. So, for example, there was someone in my life who was in a domestic violence situation, and I helped her to get to a safe place.
从道德和宗教基础来看，为了保护他人免受伤害，撒谎是正当的。比如，我生命中曾有个人处于家庭暴力环境中，我帮她找到了一个安全的地方。
And when her husband called, I said, I have no idea where she is. It's quite simply a lie, but it is a lie that is fully justified because it is information to which he is not entitled for the protection of life and limb of myself or another person.
当她丈夫打来电话时，我说，我不知道她在哪里。这确实是一个谎言，但这是一个完全正当的谎言，因为为了保护我自己或他人的生命安全，对方无权获得这些信息。
That is obviously a very hard example to argue against. She told me another one where her dog pooped all over her car, and she was late to a meeting. And when she got there, she did not tell the truth about why. She didn't want to gross anybody out. Also, none of their business.
这显然是一个很难反驳的例子。她还告诉了我另一个例子，她的狗把粪便拉满了她的车，她因此开会迟到了。当她到达时，她并没有说实话。她不想让任何人感到恶心。再说，这也不关他们的事。
Otherwise, she almost always picks honesty. When kids picked on her nieces about their weight, they came to her crying and asked, am I fat? And she says, it was really hard not to say the kinds of lies that people said to her when she was their age. But she didn't. She said, let's talk about your body and being fat. There's nothing wrong with being fat. Honesty, she says, is the only way to vulnerability and intimacy, which, of course.
除此之外，她几乎总是选择诚实。当孩子们拿她侄女的身材开玩笑时，孩子们哭着跑来问她，我是不是胖？她说，当时真的很难不去说那些她同龄时别人对她说过的谎话。但她没有。她说，我们来谈谈你的身体和肥胖这件事吧。胖没什么错。她说，诚实是获得脆弱感和亲密关系的唯一途径，当然，事实确实如此。
I was very curious how she does not lie at work. I definitely do most of my lying on the job. Not here, on the air, of course, where everything I say is deeply, thoroughly fact-checked, but just around the office, just white lies. I don't understand how you get by without a little pretending now and then in a workplace. I don't actually understand how you would get things done. Kasey has none of that.
我很好奇她是如何在工作中不撒谎的。我绝对是在工作中撒谎最多的人。当然不是在这里，在广播里，我说的每一句话都经过了深度且彻底的事实核查，但我只是在办公室周围说些无伤大雅的谎话。我不明白你怎么能在工作中完全不去伪装。我甚至不明白你该如何完成工作。Kasey则完全没有这种顾虑。
OK, let me ask you about a lie that I tell all the time at work. OK? At the end of pretty much any interview I ever do, I thank the person, and I tell them how great they were, even if they were not great, even if they were not good talkers, even if they were not able to describe the thing that we'd hoped that they would describe.
好吧，让我问你一个我在工作中经常说的谎。好吗？几乎每次采访结束时，我都会感谢对方，并告诉他们他们表现得有多棒，即使他们表现得很烂，即使他们不善言辞，即使他们没能描述出我们希望他们描述的事情。
That is what I say because it seems to me to be such a vulnerable thing to ask people to come and talk in an interview, and they don't know how it's going to go. And it's just kind of a nerve-racking thing that it seems just kind to say, you did a good job.
我之所以这么说，是因为在我看来，要求人们来接受采访是一件很需要勇气的事情，他们不知道结果会怎样。这让人感到紧张，所以说一句“你表现得很好”似乎是一种善意。
I think that most of the time, if the person you're speaking to didn't do well, that they're going to know it. And so the polite fiction is not going to reassure them. So what is the honest thing you could say in that situation? The honest thing is, coming to do this, to have these conversations and be open and vulnerable is a big thing. And I really appreciate that you did it and that you made the effort. Thank you for that. That's honest.
我认为大多数时候，如果对方表现不好，他们自己是知道的。所以那种礼貌性的虚构并不能安慰他们。那么在这种情况下，诚实的话该怎么说呢？诚实的话是：能来这里进行这些对话，敞开心扉，展现脆弱，这本身就是一件了不起的事。我非常感谢你能做到这一点并付出了努力。谢谢你。这才是诚实。
Hmm. I have to say, that's really good.
嗯。我不得不说，这真的很好。
Thank you. It's honest, and it acknowledges them.
谢谢。这很诚实，而且是对他们的认可。
I wasn't expecting you to really say something so actually useful.
我没料到你会真的说出这么有用的建议。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'll do you the favor of being honest about that.
我会卖你个人情，对这一点保持诚实。
I appreciate it.
我心领了。
One of the reasons why I wanted to talk to you today is that we're doing a whole episode of our show about inexplicable lies, lies that you just think, why lie about that? In your experience, what percentage of lies are unnecessary lies?
我今天想和你谈谈的原因之一是，我们正在为我们的节目做一整集关于“莫名其妙的谎言”的内容，那些让你不禁想问“为什么要在那种事上撒谎”的谎言。根据你的经验，有多少谎言是不必要的？
Can I say 100%? I really don't think, except in extreme circumstances, that Anne Frank is hidden in my attic situation, I don't think that lying is necessary. I think if we have honest, tactful interaction, we're always going to be the better for it.
我能说是100%吗？我真的认为，除非是在极端情况下，比如把安妮·弗兰克藏在阁楼那种情景，否则我认为撒谎是不必要的。我认为如果我们能进行诚实、讲究策略的互动，我们总会从中受益。
Yeah. All right. Thank you so much for doing this.
是的。好的。非常感谢你参加这次采访。
It's my pleasure.
这是我的荣幸。
I know that it's a vulnerable thing coming in and speaking honestly.
我知道能来这里坦诚地交流是一件需要勇气的事情。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And I really appreciate you doing that. No, I can genuinely say that you were great. You were very straightforward, and you spoke in a real way about what you really think, which is what we want.
我非常感谢你能这样做。不，我是真心实意地说你表现得很棒。你非常直率，谈论起自己真实的想法时也非常坦诚，这正是我们想要的。
Thank you. I hope it will be useful.
谢谢。希望能有所帮助。
Well, today on our program, lies that really just leave you scratching your head sometimes. Seriously, we have some fun stories for you. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的节目中，我们将讨论那些让人摸不着头脑的谎言。说真的，我们准备了一些有趣的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, "The Real L Word." OK, so to kick things off today, we're going to revisit some recent historical events. I think that's all I'm going to say for now. Dana Chivvis tells what happened.
这是《美国生活》。第一幕，“真正的L词”。好了，今天我们从回顾一些近期的历史事件开始。我想现在我只能说这么多了。Dana Chivvis来讲述发生了什么。
Liz Flock was just starting out as a reporter in 2011, living in DC, working at the Washington Post. This was the golden age of blogging and social media. Instagram was just a year old, basically a toddler. Twitter was five.
Liz Flock在2011年刚开始做记者时，住在华盛顿特区，为《华盛顿邮报》工作。那是博客和社交媒体的黄金时代。Instagram才一岁，基本上还是个蹒跚学步的孩子。Twitter五岁。
And news outlets realized they could use these blossoming tools of the internet to do a hybrid version of reporting. They called it "the breaking news blog." Liz was a reporter at the Washington Post's breaking news blog--
新闻机构意识到他们可以利用这些新兴的互联网工具来做混合型报道。他们称之为“突发新闻博客”。Liz当时是《华盛顿邮报》突发新闻博客的记者——
Called Blog Post.
叫“博客帖子”。
[LAUGHS] Very original.
[笑] 真有创意。
Very original. And what was happening at that time was the Arab Spring. So I was writing about protests in countries all over the Middle East every day for months on end.
真有创意。当时发生的事情是“阿拉伯之春”。所以我几个月来每天都在写关于中东各国抗议活动的文章。
The job was a combination of actual reporting and aggregation, basically reading other reporters' stories and various social media accounts and repackaging it all. I was doing a similar job around this time at AOL News.
这项工作结合了实际报道和聚合，基本上就是阅读其他记者的报道和各种社交媒体账户，然后重新包装这一切。当时我在美国在线新闻（AOL News）做类似的工作。
Our blog was called Surge Desk because we were supposed to create a surge of traffic for the website. Only I worked at AOL News, not the Washington Post, so I was reporting on Groundhog Day in Staten Island and writing posts about how solar flares are kind of like the sun is farting. Liz was writing about the Arab Spring.
我们的博客叫“激增台”，因为我们要为网站制造流量激增。只是我在美国在线新闻工作，而不是《华盛顿邮报》，所以我报道的是斯塔滕岛的“土拨鼠日”，还写一些关于太阳耀斑有点像太阳在放屁的文章。Liz写的是“阿拉伯之春”。
And I was writing about all these really complicated topics, and I was really scared every day writing about them.
而我写的是所有这些非常复杂的话题，每天写的时候我都很害怕。
Scared of what?
怕什么？
Just at the responsibility that I had, the tremendous responsibility to write accurately and quickly about all of these really important subjects.
就是我肩负的责任，那种准确且迅速地撰写所有这些重要题材的巨大责任。
Yeah. And it's just you and one editor, is that right?
是的。而且当时只有你和一个编辑，对吧？
Yeah, it was me and my editor, Melissa. And we were actually the number one traffic driver for the Washington Post for a while. So we would get about 3 million page views a month. And we were encouraged to keep that up. So--
对，就是我和我的编辑Melissa。事实上，我们一度是《华盛顿邮报》的第一大流量驱动力。我们每月大约有300万的页面浏览量。我们被鼓励保持这种势头。所以——
Oh, my god.
天哪。
--we posted as much as we could.
——我们尽可能多地发文章。
To keep up with all this from her desk in DC, she followed a bunch of social media accounts and blogs. The Arab Spring, you might remember, was one of the first big social movements to use these online tools to organize. Rightly or wrongly, it was called the "Facebook revolution."
为了从她在特区的办公桌上跟上所有这些报道，她关注了一堆社交媒体账号和博客。你可能还记得，“阿拉伯之春”是首批利用这些在线工具进行组织的重大社会运动之一。不管对错，它被称为“Facebook革命”。
One of the blogs Liz followed was written by a 35-year-old Syrian-American woman named Amina Arraf, who had recently moved back to Damascus from the US. Her blog was called A Gay Girl in Damascus.
Liz关注的博客之一是由一位35岁的叙利亚裔美国女性撰写的，名叫Amina Arraf，她最近从美国搬回了大马士革。她的博客叫“大马士革的女同性恋”。
She writes about her complex identity of being an out lesbian in conservative Syria, having grown up in the US. And on the blog, she writes poetry. She writes history. She writes what are basically like foreign policy op-eds.
她写关于自己复杂的身份：作为一名在保守的叙利亚公开出柜的女同性恋，同时又是在美国长大的。在博客上，她写诗，写历史。她写的东西基本上就像外交政策的专栏文章。
She's openly critical of the Bashar al-Assad regime, at a time when the regime was arresting, torturing, and murdering critics and activists. In one post, titled "Irony," there's a photo she's taken of a billboard. On it, Assad's smiling face and the headscratcher of a tagline, "Syria believes in you." Below the photo, Amina writes, "SURE," in all caps and multiple exclamation points. She's provocative.
她公开批评巴沙尔·阿萨德政权，当时该政权正在逮捕、折磨和谋杀批评者和活动人士。在题为“讽刺”的一篇文章中，有一张她拍的广告牌照片。上面是阿萨德微笑着的脸，还有一句让人费解的标语：“叙利亚相信你。”在照片下方，Amina写道：“当然。”用的是全大写字母和多个感叹号。她很有挑衅性。
She sometimes writes more sexy poetry, I would say.
我想她有时会写些更色情的诗。
Huh.
哈。
I forgot about this, but I went back to it, and there was one piece called "Testimony of Jasmine." And she writes, "My sex to your sex grinding in time, with sounds of the city stretched out below." And it goes on and on.
我差点忘了，但我回看了下，有一篇叫“茉莉花的证词”。她写道：“我的性与你的性，在节奏中磨合，伴随着城市下方延伸的声音。”而且这还没完没了。
Legally, I can't let her read you the rest of this poem-- FCC rules.
按法律规定，我不能让她给你读这首诗的其余部分——FCC（联邦通信委员会）的规定。
So a young, pretty Syrian-American lesbian taunting the brutal Assad regime. It's not much surprise when the secret police show up at her house one day.
所以，一个年轻、漂亮、叙利亚裔的美国女同性恋在嘲弄残暴的阿萨德政权。当秘密警察有一天出现在她家门口时，也就不足为奇了。
On April 26, Amina publishes a post titled "My Father the Hero." She describes a harrowing scene. It was the middle of the night, and these two young, muscly guys in leather jackets rang the doorbell of her family's home. They've come for Amina. They know about her blog, know that she's a lesbian. They threaten to rape her.
4月26日，Amina发表了一篇题为“我的英雄父亲”的文章。她描述了一个惊心动魄的场面。那是深夜，两个穿着皮夹克的年轻健壮男子敲响了她家的门。他们是来找Amina的。他们知道她的博客，知道她是女同性恋。他们威胁要强奸她。
But Amina's father argues with them, chides them. He knows them, knows their families. He says to them, quote, "Do you know what is our family name? You do? Then you know where we stood when Muhammad, peace be upon him, went to Medina. You know who it was who liberated al-Quds. You know, too, maybe, that my father fought to save this country from the foreigners." He tells them to leave, and they do. Amina's post goes viral. Back in DC, Liz decides to write about it.
但Amina的父亲与他们争论，斥责他们。他认识他们，也认识他们的家人。他对他们说，引述：“你知道我们家族的名字吗？你知道？那你应该知道当穆罕默德（愿主福安之）去麦地那时，我们站在哪一边。你知道是谁解放了圣城。你也可能知道，我父亲曾为拯救这个国家而与外国人战斗。”他命令他们离开，他们就走了。Amina的文章疯传。回到特区，Liz决定写关于这件事的文章。
So the second I read her post, "My Father, My Hero," I immediately reach out to her for an interview. I mean, we were interviewing lots of activists, but she is like the dream interview because she's so interesting.
所以读到她那篇“我的英雄父亲”文章的瞬间，我立刻联系她想要采访。我的意思是，我们在采访很多活动人士，但她是那种梦寐以求的受访者，因为她太有趣了。
Amina emails her back, and the next day, Liz publishes a post-- "Syria blogger says she faced arrest but remains defiant." In the article, Amina tells Liz, quote, "If we want to live in a free country, we need to start acting as though we live in a free country."
Amina回复了邮件，第二天，Liz发表了一篇文章——“叙利亚博主称面临逮捕但保持反抗”。在文章中，Amina告诉Liz，引述：“如果我们想生活在一个自由的国家，我们就需要开始像生活在一个自由的国家那样去行动。”
Six weeks later, Liz goes into the office.
六周后，Liz来到办公室。
I am checking the blogs and social media, and I see that on Gay Girl in Damascus, there's a post not by Amina. And it says, "Dear friends of Amina, I'm Amina's cousin, and I have the following information to share. Earlier today, at approximately 6:00 PM Damascus time, Amina was walking in the area of this bus station."
我正在查看博客和社交媒体，看到在“大马士革的女同性恋”上，有一篇不是Amina写的文章。它写道：“Amina的朋友们，我是Amina的堂兄，我有以下信息要分享。今天早些时候，大马士革时间下午6点左右，Amina正在该车站附近行走。”
The post says Amina was abducted by three government agents.
文章说Amina被三名政府特工绑架了。
"Then they hustled her into a red Dacia Logan with a window sticker of Bashar al-Assad."
“然后他们把她塞进了一辆红色的达契亚Logan车里，车窗上贴着巴沙尔·阿萨德的贴纸。”
Hmm.
嗯。
"The men are presumed to be members of the security services. Amina's present location is unknown."
“这些人被认为是安全部门的成员。Amina目前下落不明。”
Liz was shocked and upset by this news.
Liz对这个消息感到震惊和难过。
This was happening a lot at this point that activists were getting kind of hauled off the streets, but this was a person that I felt intimately connected to. Like I knew her whole story at this point. Like I had read her whole blog.
当时这种情况经常发生，活动人士被从街上抓走，但这确实是一个我感觉关系密切的人。就像我已经读过她的整个博客，了解她的整个故事一样。
Yeah.
是的。
And so it was really scary. And obviously, as a gay woman and a woman speaking out against the regime, you're thinking that this person's dead.
所以这真的很可怕。而且显然，作为一名女同性恋，一名公开反对政权的女性，你会认为这个人已经死了。
Homosexuality was, and still is, illegal in Syria. Liz writes a post about Amina's disappearance. So does the Washington Post's Syria correspondent, and The New York Times and The Guardian and others. Liz calls the State Department. They tell her they're looking into it. A Twitter campaign gets going, #FreeAmina, and multiple Facebook groups, which get over 10,000 followers overnight. It's a big deal. And then--
同性恋在叙利亚过去是，现在依然是非法的。Liz写了一篇关于Amina失踪的文章。《华盛顿邮报》的叙利亚特派员也写了，还有《纽约时报》、《卫报》等。Liz给国务院打了电话。他们告诉她他们正在调查。一个推特运动开始了，#FreeAmina，还有多个Facebook群组，一夜之间获得了超过1万名粉丝。这可是件大事。然后——
Oh, so all of a sudden, doubts start popping up about Amina. It really all started very quickly. Like on the same day that she wrote that she was kidnapped or detained by security forces, or that the cousin writes that, Andy Carvin, who's NPR's Twitter senior strategist and had this huge following, basically asks, has anyone met Amina?
噢，突然之间，关于Amina的怀疑开始出现了。一切真的开始得非常快。就在她写自己被安全部队绑架或拘留的那天，或者说她的堂兄写那篇文章的那天，NPR的推特高级策略师Andy Carvin，他有巨大的影响力，基本上问了：有人见过Amina吗？
Has anyone actually met Amina in person, not just on the internet? It's a good question. In fact, when Liz emailed Amina asking for an interview, Amina had responded that for her own safety, she couldn't talk on the phone, so Liz had sent her questions by email.
有人在现实生活中真的见过Amina吗，不仅仅是在互联网上？这是一个好问题。事实上，当Liz发邮件给Amina请求采访时，Amina回复说为了自己的安全，她不能打电话，所以Liz是通过电子邮件发送问题的。
Do you remember the "oh, fuck" moment that you had when you realized people were doubting her identity?
你还记得当你意识到人们怀疑她的身份时，那个“噢，糟了”的时刻吗？
Yes. I remember Andy asking that question on Twitter, and I remember thinking, wow, if this person isn't real, I have interviewed them saying that she is and given them a platform and caused this blog to probably increase in popularity. And yeah, that's a really scary moment as a super young journalist.
记得。我记得Andy在推特上问了那个问题，我记得我在想，哇，如果这个人不是真实的，我采访了她，报道说她是真实的，还给了她一个平台，导致这个博客可能变得更受欢迎了。是的，作为一个超级年轻的记者，那真是一个非常可怕的时刻。
I don't know if you remember this New Yorker cartoon from 1993 where it says, on the internet, no one knows you're a dog, and it has this dog at the computer.
我不确定你是否记得1993年那幅《纽约客》漫画，上面写着“在互联网上，没人知道你是一条狗”，漫画里有一只狗在电脑前。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So obviously, people were thinking about this all the way back to the '90s, but I know I wasn't. It's not that I was trusting everything I read online, but I think I just didn't expect this gay Syrian woman activist who was blogging like a lot of other Syrian activists that were all totally legitimate, to be someone so different. And yeah, I mean, as the story progressed, it got creepier and creepier.
所以很显然，人们从90年代就开始思考这个问题了，但我知道我当时没有。并不是说我信任我在网上读到的所有东西，但我认为我只是没想到这位女同性恋叙利亚活动人士博主，竟然会是一个完全不同的人。是的，随着故事的发展，它变得越来越令人毛骨悚然。
The Wall Street Journal reported that the photo of Amina on A Gay Girl in Damascus was actually a photo of a woman named Jelena Lecic, who is of Croatian descent and was living in London at the time. So Liz and her editor, Melissa Bell, start trying to figure out who Amina actually is.
《华尔街日报》报道称，“大马士革的女同性恋”上Amina的照片实际上是一个名叫Jelena Lecic的女人的照片，她是克罗地亚裔，当时住在伦敦。所以Liz和她的编辑Melissa Bell开始试图弄清楚Amina到底是谁。
They look up the IP address of the Gay Girl blog. It leads back to Scotland, to the University of Edinburgh. And they get a mailing address for Amina from one of her online friends. It's a house in Georgia, the state, not the country, owned by an American couple who were studying in Scotland. They narrow in on the wife, a woman named Britta.
他们查询了博客的IP地址。它追溯到苏格兰的爱丁堡大学。他们从Amina的一位在线朋友那里得到了一个邮寄地址。那是乔治亚州（美国那个州，不是国家）的一所房子，房主是一对在美国留学的美国夫妇。他们锁定了妻子，一个名叫Britta的女人。
Britta was studying Syrian economic development. She had written about Syria for a Quaker group that she was the head of. And she had even posted photos of her visiting Syria with her husband, and she had posted this photo on the photo website Picasa, showing a billboard of a smiling Syrian President Bashar al-Assad with the slogan "Syria believes in you."
Britta正在研究叙利亚经济发展。她曾为一个她担任负责人的教友会组织写过关于叙利亚的文章。她甚至发布了和丈夫访问叙利亚的照片，她还在图片网站Picasa上发布了这张照片，显示着一张叙利亚总统巴沙尔·阿萨德微笑着的广告牌，口号是“叙利亚相信你”。
"Syria believes in you." It's the same photo from Amina's blog post titled "Irony."
“叙利亚相信你。”这和Amina题为“讽刺”的博文中的照片是一模一样的。
I mean, it's not a photo that exists, like, thousands of times on the internet. It is only in these two places. And we're like, oh, my god, this is the exact same photo.
我的意思是，那不是一张在互联网上出现过成千上万次的照片。它只存在于这两个地方。我们当时就想，噢，天哪，这简直就是同一张照片。
That's a smoking gun. You never get that clear of an answer.
那是决定性的证据。你很难得到这么明确的答案。
Totally! Totally.
没错！完全正确。
So they got to call Britta, but they can't find Britta's phone number. But they do find Britta's mom's phone number. They call her up.
所以他们得给Britta打电话，但他们找不到Britta的电话号码。但他们确实找到了Britta妈妈的电话号码。他们打了过去。
We explain the whole situation to her. I remember thinking, this is so bizarre. Like, I'm sorry, but I think that your daughter is this person posting on this blog pretending to be a lesbian woman in Syria. And to her credit, she was not like, please leave me alone. She basically said, wow, this is so interesting. And I don't think it's Britta. I think it's Tom.
我们向她解释了整个情况。我记得我在想，这太离奇了。我是说，对不起，但我认为你的女儿就是那个在博客上发帖假装是叙利亚女同性恋的人。值得称赞的是，她没有说“请别再烦我了”。她基本上说，哇，这太有趣了。而且我不认为那是Britta。我认为那是Tom。
Tom, Britta's husband, Tom MacMaster.
Tom，Britta的丈夫，Tom MacMaster。
And she was like, he's so involved emotionally with Syria. His interest has evolved from there. And she even said, Britta complains about him spending his whole day on the computer.
她还说，他在情感上对叙利亚投入太深了。他的兴趣就是从那里演变而来的。她甚至说，Britta抱怨他整天都在电脑上。
Aha! One of those husbands. What they learned about Tom-- he's 40 years old, a Middle East fanatic, obsessed with the Israeli-Palestine conflict. He's getting his master's degree at the University of Edinburgh. There's more.
啊哈！那种丈夫之一。他们了解到的关于Tom的事实——他40岁，是个中东狂热分子，沉迷于以色列-巴勒斯坦冲突。他正在爱丁堡大学读硕士。还有更多。
We find that Tom's cat is named Meowmar J. Katdafi, which is basically the Libyan leader, Muammar Gadhafi's name. It's just getting ridiculous at this point, to be honest. And then we find one more thing. And that is we find that Amina gave a five star review to Tom's ESL school that he has in Atlanta.
我们发现Tom的猫名叫“Meowmar J. Katdafi”（喵马·J·卡扎菲），基本上就是利比亚领导人穆阿迈尔·卡扎菲的名字。老实说，到了这一步简直荒唐透顶。然后我们又发现了一件事。那就是我们发现Amina给Tom在亚特兰大开的英语学校写了一个五星好评。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I know. I know. And this is when it starts to just feel like, oh, my god, this guy is absurd.
我知道。我知道。这就是那种开始感觉“天哪，这家伙简直不可理喻”的时候。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
So as "Amina A," Amina writes, "Great school, great teachers. This is probably the best value for anyone who wants to learn English in Atlanta."
所以，作为“Amina A”，Amina写道：“很棒的学校，很棒的老师。对于任何想在亚特兰大学习英语的人来说，这可能是最好的选择。”
Oh, god.
噢，天哪。
OK, one last important detail about Tom's extracurricular activities.
好了，关于Tom的课外活动，还有一个重要的细节。
So Amina is super active online, and part of that is flirting with women.
所以Amina在网上非常活跃，其中一部分就是和女性调情。
She's not just writing lesbian erotica. She's on dating sites. She's had an online girlfriend in Canada for the last six months. The girlfriend started one of the Facebook campaigns to free Amina. And Amina--
她不仅仅是在写女同性恋色情文学。她还在交友网站上。她在加拿大有一个在线女友已经六个月了。那个女友发起了Facebook上的“释放Amina”运动之一。而Amina——
She's also flirting and writing on the blog of this person, Paula Brooks, who has a very popular website about being lesbian called LezGetReal.
她还在跟这个人Paula Brooks调情，并在她的博客上留言，Paula Brooks有一个非常受欢迎的关于女同性恋的网站，叫“LezGetReal”。
Nice.
不错。
LezGetReal.com, for those of you who don't remember the sapphic offerings of the internet in the year 2011, was a website where a variety of writers blogged about lesbianism and the lesbian news of the day. Amina had written a bunch on LezGetReal.com. And the founder, Paula Brooks, had encouraged her to start A Gay Girl in Damascus that winter. And, Paula told Liz, they'd had a little online fling.
LezGetReal.com，对于那些不记得2011年互联网上那些萨福（Sapphic）内容的听众来说，是一个各种作家博客讨论女同性恋及相关新闻的网站。Amina在上面写了很多文章。创始人Paula Brooks鼓励她在那个冬天创办了“大马士革的女同性恋”。而且，Paula告诉Liz，她们之间曾有一段小小的网络恋情。
Paula and Amina spoke all the time online and even were engaging in a relationship, that it wasn't clear how flirty it was, slash sexual it was. I think it seems like it was definitely romantic/sexual.
Paula和Amina在网上经常交谈，甚至正在建立一种关系，虽然不清楚调情和性行为的程度。我觉得看起来绝对是浪漫/性关系。
And this is over email? Or they're like--
这是通过电子邮件？还是她们像——
This is all online, like email and blog posts and corresponding about the blog posts.
这些都是在网上进行的，比如电子邮件和博客文章，以及关于博客文章的通信。
Liz explained to Paula what was going on with Amina.
Liz向Paula解释了关于Amina发生了什么。
Paula was outraged [CHUCKLES] that this person was pretending to be a lesbian, this man was pretending to be a lesbian.
Paula非常愤怒[轻笑]，因为这个人在假装女同性恋，这个男人在假装女同性恋。
LezGetReal.com posted an apology to readers for publishing 19 articles Amina had supposedly written.
LezGetReal.com发了一份道歉声明，为发布了Amina所谓的19篇文章向读者道歉。
Time to confront Tom. Liz reaches him on the phone. He's on vacation with his wife in Istanbul.
是时候去对峙Tom了。Liz在电话里联系上了他。他正在和妻子在伊斯坦布尔度假。
And I remember they're laughing a lot. Basically, they laugh off the idea that either of one of them could be Amina.
我记得他们在大笑。基本上，他们对他们中任何一个人可能是Amina的想法付之一笑。
Hmm.
嗯。
And Tom is kind of sarcastically laughing at me. And he says something like, look, if I'm the genius who pulled this off, I would just say, yes, it's me, and I would write a book.
Tom有点讽刺地对我笑。他说了一些类似的话：“看，如果我真的是那个成功瞒天过海的天才，我会直接说，是的，就是我，然后写本书。”
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
And--
然后——
"The genius." [LAUGHS]
“天才”。[笑]
Genius.
天才。
Yeah.
是的。
And then I went through all the connections we had, which at this point were, like, 15 different connections. And I think we called him a second day in a row. And then he started to get aggressive with us.
然后我列举了我们掌握的所有联系，到那时已经有15个不同的关联了。我想我们第二天又给他打了一次电话。然后他开始对我们变得很有攻击性。
Hmm.
嗯。
And he said, thanks a lot for tracking us down, and hung up on me.
他说，谢谢你们找到我们，然后挂断了我的电话。
Other reporters had figured it out, too. Liz and Melissa decide to run with the story that A Gay Girl in Damascus was actually Tom, a white dude living in Scotland. But before they can publish, Tom beats them to it. He confesses in a post on A Gay Girl.
其他记者也查出来了。Liz和Melissa决定发布这个故事，揭露“大马士革的女同性恋”实际上是Tom，一个住在苏格兰的白人男。但在她们能发布之前，Tom抢先一步。他在“大马士革的女同性恋”上发帖坦白了。
And the title of the blog is changed from A Gay Girl in Damascus to-- let me find it-- "A hoax that got way out of hand. I never meant to hurt anyone."
博客标题从“大马士革的女同性恋”改为——让我找找——“一个失控的骗局。我从没想过要伤害任何人。”
Hmm. It's less pithy than A Gay Girl in Damascus.
嗯。比原来的标题少了一点简洁。
Yeah. Well, actually, he retitles it A Hoax.
是的。事实上，他改成了“一个骗局”。
Oh, OK. [CHUCKLES]
噢，好的。[轻笑]
And then there's that subtitle, so.
然后有那个副标题，所以。
Tom writes the quintessential non-apology apology, says that while the narrative voice might have been fictional, he was describing a very real situation on the ground in Damascus, and he doesn't think he harmed anyone. Maybe you saw the whole thing coming, internet scams being what they are these days. Maybe you're thinking, hey, this whole story is a scam. I can't believe I paid no dollars for this. But calm down a second. There's more.
Tom写了一份典型的“不道歉式道歉”，说虽然叙事的声音可能是虚构的，但他描述的是大马士革当地真实存在的情况，而且他不认为他伤害了任何人。也许你早预料到了这一切，现在的互联网骗局就是这样。也许你在想，嘿，这整个故事都是个骗局。我不敢相信我竟然没花一分钱看了这个。但先别急。还有更多。
Liz and her editor, Melissa, published their story on Sunday, six days after Amina was supposedly abducted. Their headline is "A Gay Girl in Damascus Comes Clean." After they post their article, Liz and Melissa are talking with a more senior editor. Everyone's pretty happy with the story. But there's something still nagging at Liz, a detail she can't get out of her head. It has to do with that other lesbian she interviewed, Paula Brooks, from LezGetReal.com. She says to her editors--
Liz和她的编辑Melissa在周日发布了她们的故事，距离Amina所谓的被绑架仅六天。她们的标题是“大马士革的女同性恋真相大白”。文章发布后，Liz和Melissa正在与一位更高级的编辑交谈。大家对这个故事都很满意。但有一件事仍然困扰着Liz，一个她挥之不去的细节。这与她采访的另一位女同性恋有关，来自LezGetReal.com的Paula Brooks。她对编辑说——
So I interviewed Paula, but I actually didn't interview Paula because she's deaf. And I talked to her father because she's deaf. And he said she can't speak on the phone. And her father weirdly knew a lot about the story. And basically now I'm doubting that everyone is real. Do you guys think that Paula Brooks is also not real?
我采访了Paula，但我实际上没有采访到Paula，因为她是聋人。我和她父亲谈过，因为她是聋人。他奇怪地对这个故事了解很多。基本上现在我怀疑每个人都不是真实的。你们认为Paula Brooks也是虚构的吗？
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
Liz had emailed with Paula Brooks. Paula had sent Liz a photo of her driver's license as proof of identity, but Liz had only ever spoken with Paula's dad.
Liz曾与Paula Brooks通过电子邮件联系。Paula发给Liz一张驾驶证的照片作为身份证明，但Liz只和Paula的父亲通过话。
It's the exact same thing as with Amina. Like, I can't talk on the phone, and so I'll have to do it in this alternate way. And but in this case, I'm deaf. And I didn't want to doubt Paula being deaf, but the dad was so weird.
这和Amina的情况完全一样。就像是：我不能打电话，所以我必须用这种替代方式。但在这种情况下，我是聋人。我不想怀疑Paula是聋人，但她父亲太奇怪了。
Right.
对。
And now I'm basically like, is every single person on the internet actually just a white dude pretending to be someone else?
现在我基本上是在想，互联网上的每一个人其实都是一个白人男假装成别人吗？
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
So instead of celebrating a great scoop outing Tom as Amina, Liz dove straight into investigating Paula Brooks.
所以Liz没有去庆祝揭露Tom作为Amina的伟大独家报道，而是直接开始调查Paula Brooks。
[SIGHS] So I call back the dad, and I basically say, I know you're Paula Brooks.
[叹气] 我给那位父亲回了电话，基本上说，我知道你就是Paula Brooks。
Oh, wow, you just went straight for it.
噢，哇，你直接点破了。
I think we just went straight for it. Maybe we said, are you Paula Brooks? And he basically just said, yes.
我想我们就是直接点破了。也许我们说的是，你是Paula Brooks吗？他基本上就说，是的。
Oh, what?
噢，什么？
My name is Bill Graber. Yep.
我叫Bill Graber。是的。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
He said, I'm Bill Graber. Then I said, who are you, Bill Graber? And it turned out he was a retired construction worker who lived in Ohio.
他说，我是Bill Graber。然后我说，你是谁，Bill Graber？结果发现他是一名住在俄亥俄州的退休建筑工人。
Bill told Liz he'd had some lesbian friends who were mistreated, and he wanted to help. He also wanted a platform where he could write in support of repealing Don't Ask, Don't Tell. The real Paula Brooks, Bill explained, was his partner, who didn't know he'd been using her identity online to pose as a lesbian.
Bill告诉Liz，他有一些受虐待的女同性恋朋友，他想提供帮助。他还想要一个平台，让他可以写文章支持废除“不问不说”政策。真正的Paula Brooks，Bill解释说，是他的伴侣，她根本不知道他一直在网上用她的身份冒充女同性恋。
Basically, Bill said that by running LezGetReal, he was surfacing issues for the lesbian community and helping in that way.
基本上，Bill说通过经营LezGetReal，他是在为女同性恋群体引发关注并提供帮助。
And having a flirtation with Amina.
还有和Amina调情。
Yes. I mean, I would have loved to get those chats between Amina and Paula, a.k.a. Tom and Bill, two white men flirting with themselves, each thinking the other one is a lesbian.
是的。我的意思是，我真的很想看看Amina和Paula，也就是Tom和Bill之间的那些聊天记录，两个白人男在互相调情，每个人都认为对方是女同性恋。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
But I never got those chats, so we'll have to let our imaginations run wild on that one. But yeah. And you know what's funny? I still remember this. I was like, Bill, how does it feel to know that you were flirting with another dude, thinking it was a lesbian? And he was definitely put off by that. And he said this thing to me. He was just like, it was a major sock puppet hoax crashed into another major sock puppet hoax.
但我从未得到那些聊天记录，所以只能留给我们的想象了。但真的。你知道什么很有趣吗？我至今记得这一点。我当时就说，Bill，知道你在和一个男人调情，却以为她是女同性恋，感觉如何？他显然被那个问题冒犯了。他对我说了这么一句话。他就是说，这简直是一个巨大的“木偶骗局”撞上了另一个巨大的“木偶骗局”。
For the uninitiated, a sock puppet hoax is when someone uses a false identity online. The day after they published their story about Tom being Amina, Liz and Melissa published another one, with the headline, "Paula Brooks, editor of LezGetReal, also a man."
对于圈外人，“木偶骗局”是指某人在网上使用虚假身份。在他们发表关于Tom就是Amina的故事后的第二天，Liz和Melissa发表了另一篇标题为“LezGetReal编辑Paula Brooks也是个男人”的文章。
I mean, to the point. At this point, you can tell by how plugged in everyone is because we don't even need to explain more than that because everyone knows what's going on and is glued to their computers. I mean, some people-- and Syrian activists in particular-- were really upset by the whole situation, especially about Gay Girl in Damascus, because it was taking needed-- it was like boy who cried wolf situation, which is like, who's going to trust Syrian activists posting about this after this situation?
我的意思是，一针见血。到了这一步，你可以看出每个人有多投入，因为我们甚至不需要多做解释，因为每个人都知道发生了什么，都盯着他们的电脑。我的意思是，有些人——特别是叙利亚活动人士——对整个情况感到非常愤怒，特别是关于“大马士革的女同性恋”，因为它消耗了必要的——这就像是“狼来了”的情况，谁还会信任发布此类消息的叙利亚活动人士？
By the time Tom's little lie had rolled all the way downhill, it was a pretty sizable lie with real-world consequences. The Syrian government used it to suggest that everyone in the West was lying about the Assad regime's murderous tactics against activists and bloggers. They used it to suggest that gay people in Syria were really just agents of the West.
当Tom的小谎言一路滚下山坡时，那已经是一个相当大的谎言，并且产生了现实后果。叙利亚政府利用它暗示西方人关于阿萨德政权对抗活动人士和博主的残暴手段的所有报道都是谎言。他们利用它暗示叙利亚的同性恋者实际上只是西方的代理人。
In retrospect, Amina's writing, it's so bad. Like when her father supposedly says to the secret police, "You know where we stood when Muhammad, peace be upon him, went to Medina," it's like the 1950s Hollywood version of how a Syrian man would talk.
回想起来，Amina的文笔实在太差了。就像当她父亲所谓的对秘密警察说：“你知道当穆罕默德（愿主福安之）去麦地那时，我们站在哪一边，”这简直是50年代好莱坞版本的叙利亚男人谈吐。
But what was good about Amina's writing-- Tom's writing-- is that it played for emotion. It confirmed what we were all feeling here in the West, what excited us about the Arab Spring. Democracy was ascendant. The bad guys were going down. The lesbians were taking over, or whatever. Amina was the lie we all wanted.
但Amina的文字——Tom的文字——好在哪里呢，是它触动了情感。它证实了我们西方人内心深处的感觉，那些让我们对“阿拉伯之春”感到兴奋的东西。民主正在崛起。坏人即将倒台。女同性恋们正在接管一切，诸如此类。Amina是我们大家都想要的那个谎言。
I reached out to Tom, Bill, and Britta for this story. Tom and Bill definitely did not want to talk to me. Britta didn't respond. But the day after he was outed, Tom did some press. He said he had wanted to wind Amina down for a while. And he was going on vacation, so having her abducted was kind of his out-of-office message.
我为了这个故事联系了Tom、Bill和Britta。Tom和Bill绝对不想和我谈。Britta没有回复。但在他被揭露的第二天，Tom接受了一些采访。他说他其实早就想结束Amina这个身份了。而且他正要去度假，所以让她被绑架算是他的一种“离岗自动回复”。
Yeah, man, the internet, huh?
是啊，兄弟，互联网，对吧？
The internet. I mean, it's-- oh, god, I know. And it was so fun for just a short period of time where everyone was just like, is this thing on? Can I tell you about what I ate?
互联网。我的意思是，它——噢，天哪，我知道。而在那一小段时间里，它确实很有趣，每个人都像是在说，这个东西开着吗？我能告诉你我吃了什么吗？
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
A lot's changed since then. The Washington Post, where Liz worked, is now owned by Jeff Bezos. Twitter is owned by Elon Musk. Instagram is owned by Facebook. Facebook has done away with fact-checking. And the president has his own social media platform, called Truth Social, where he regularly posts falsehoods and conspiracy theories.
从那时起发生了很多变化。《华盛顿邮报》，Liz曾经工作的地方，现在被杰夫·贝佐斯拥有。Twitter被埃隆·马斯克拥有。Instagram被Facebook拥有。Facebook已经取消了事实核查。总统有自己的社交媒体平台，叫“真相社交”，他经常在那里发布虚假信息和阴谋论。
It kind of makes you long for the good old days, when the internet wasn't dominated by the most powerful, and people still cared what was true and what wasn't. The truth-- so retro. It's a whole new world now, except over here on the dusty, old radio, where I still can't say "shit" or "piss" or "fuck" or "cunt" or "cocksucker" or "motherfucker" or "tits"-- not even "tits"-- because, of course, think of the chaos that would ensue if I did.
这让人渴望往昔的美好时光，那时互联网还没被最有权势的人所主宰，人们还在乎什么是真、什么是假。真理——太复古了。现在是全新的世界了，除了在这落满灰尘的老式电台中，我还不能说“shit”、“piss”、“fuck”、“cunt”、“cocksucker”、“motherfucker”或“tits”——连“tits”也不能说——因为，当然，想想如果我说了会引发怎样的混乱。
Dana Chivvis is a reporter on our program. Liz Flock is still a reporter, but now she spends years reporting her stories. Her latest book, The Furies, which she traveled to Syria multiple times for, is out in paperback.
Dana Chivvis是我们节目的记者。Liz Flock仍然是记者，但现在她花几年时间来报道她的故事。她的最新著作《复仇女神》，她为这本书多次前往叙利亚，现在已经出了平装本。
Coming up, an American dad makes an impassioned argument for more unnecessary lies. Also, Masha Gessen. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一位美国父亲为更多不必要的谎言进行了充满激情的辩护。还有Masha Gessen。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "That's a Weird Thing to Lie About." We have stories today of unnecessary lies, outrageous lies that make you wonder, why lie about that in the first place? We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Bully Pulpit."
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“那是一个奇怪的谎言”。我们今天的故事讲述了不必要的谎言、离谱的谎言，让你怀疑，为什么起初要在那件事上撒谎？我们现在来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“布道台”。
There's a particular kind of lie that somebody who's been on our show a few times, Masha Gessen, wrote about a few years ago. And when I read what they wrote, I realized, oh, I had not thought about this as a specific way that a person can lie that is different from all the other ways a person can lie.
有一种特定类型的谎言，曾多次上我们节目的Masha Gessen几年前写过。当我读到他们写的内容时，我意识到，噢，我以前从没把这看作是个人撒谎的一种特定方式，它不同于人们撒谎的所有其他方式。
It's a kind of lie that President Trump does a lot. He kicked off his presidency with one of these lies in the very first minutes on the very first day of his very first term. You may remember that he insisted that the crowds at his inauguration were bigger than they were, even though photos clearly showed that he was wrong.
这是一种特朗普总统经常使用的谎言。他在任期的第一天、第一分钟，就以其中一个谎言开启了他的总统任期。你可能记得，他坚称参加他就职典礼的人群比实际人数要多，尽管照片清楚地表明他错了。
But he also lied about the weather because it was rainy. And the cameras panned to all these former presidents. And Trump claimed that when he started to speak, the sun came out, and the clouds parted, as though God herself were on his side. And it was an easily checkable story. It was definitely not true.
但他还撒谎说天气情况，因为当时下着雨。摄像机扫向所有这些前总统。特朗普声称，当他开始讲话时，太阳出来了，云层散开了，就好像上帝本身站在他这一边一样。这是一个很容易核实的故事。它绝对不是真的。
In fact, for anybody who had watched the inauguration, which was a lot of us, it was just right there. We had just seen it.
事实上，对于任何观看就职典礼的人来说，我们中的许多人都是，它就在那儿。我们刚刚亲眼看到了。
And then he emerges from this and says that that's something entirely different than we saw with our lying eyes.
然后他从这些谎言中走出来，说那与我们用受骗的眼睛看到的情况完全不同。
Let me ask you to read-- you write about this very enjoyably. Let me ask you to read this passage. I'm going to hand you a copy. Let's start here and continue up here. We'll skip this little bit, and then we'll keep going.
让我请你读——你写得非常引人入胜。让我请你读这一段。我会给你一份副本。让我们从这里开始，一直到上面。我们跳过这一小段，然后继续。
OK. "Lies can serve a number of functions. People lie to deflect, to avoid embarrassment or evade punishment by creating doubt, to escape confrontation or lighten the blow, to make themselves appear better, to get others to do or give something, and even to entertain.
好的。“谎言可以服务多种功能。人们撒谎是为了转移视线，通过制造怀疑来避免尴尬或规避惩罚，为了逃避对抗或减轻打击，为了让自己看起来更好，为了让别人做某事或给予某物，甚至是为了娱乐。
However unskilled a person may be at lying, they usually hope that the lie will be convincing. Executives want shareholders to think that they have devised a foolproof path to profits. Defendants want juries to believe that there is a chance that someone else committed the crime.
无论一个人撒谎的技巧有多拙劣，他们通常都希望谎言能让人信服。高管希望股东认为他们制定了万无一失的盈利路径。被告希望陪审团相信有可能是别人犯下的罪行。
People in relationships want their partners to think that they have never even considered cheating. Guests want the host to think that they like their fish overcooked. These lies can be annoying or amusing, but they are surmountable. They collapse in the face of facts.
恋爱中的人希望伴侣认为他们从未考虑过出轨。客人希望主人认为他们喜欢烤得过头的鱼。这些谎言可能令人恼火或好笑，但它们是可以克服的。它们在事实面前会崩塌。
The Trumpian lie is different. It is the power lie or the bully lie. It is the lie of the bigger kid who took your hat and is wearing it while denying that he took it. There is no defense against this lie because the point of the lie is to assert power, to show I can say what I want, when I want to.
特朗普式的谎言则不同。这是权力谎言或霸凌谎言。这是那个抢了你帽子并戴着它，同时否认自己抢了它的那个大孩子的谎言。这种谎言无法辩护，因为谎言的目的就是宣示权力，展示‘我可以随时随地想说什么就说什么’。
The power lie conjures a different reality that demands that you choose between your experience and the bully's demands. Are you going to insist that you're wet from the rain or give in and say that the sun is shining?"
这种权力谎言构建了一个不同的现实，要求你在你的亲身经历和霸凌者的要求之间做出选择。你是要坚持说你被雨淋湿了，还是屈服并说太阳正照耀着？”
I have to say, since reading that passage in your book a few weeks ago, I feel like it's like you gave a name to something that I had known was there, but hadn't put a finger on what it was, like I hadn't named myself. This is a particular phenomenon, a particular way of lying that Donald Trump does.
我不得不说，自从几周前读到你书中的那段话，我感觉就像你给某种我一直知道它存在，但没能准确指出它是什么的东西起了一个名字，就好像我没有自己命名过它。这是一种特定的现象，一种唐纳德·特朗普使用的特定的撒谎方式。
And since I read that, I feel like I see this kind of power lie or bully lie from Trump and from his team come up in the news over and over. So, for example, Ukraine started the war with Russia; USAID sent $50 million worth of condoms to Hamas; China controls the Panama Canal.
自从我读了那段，我就觉得我看到特朗普和他的团队一遍又一遍地在新闻中上演这种权力谎言或霸凌谎言。所以，例如：乌克兰发动了与俄罗斯的战争；美国国际开发署向哈马斯发送了价值5000万美元的安全套；中国控制着巴拿马运河。
Yeah, these are bully lies. And I'm seeing more and more of the impossibility of standing up to it because there are now a lot of these people, right? It's not just Trump. The first administration, it was Trump and his lies and a bunch of sycophants. Now they're kind of all, particularly Trump and Musk, are just kind of running-- one is constantly getting ahead of the other. Federal employees have fortunes in the tens of millions with a salary of $180,000.
是的，这些都是霸凌谎言。我越来越多地看到反抗这种谎言的不可能性，因为现在有很多人都在这样做，对吧？不仅仅是特朗普。第一届政府时，那是特朗普和他的谎言，加上一群阿谀奉承者。现在他们几乎所有人，特别是特朗普和马斯克，都在……一个接一个地领先。联邦雇员拿着18万美元的薪水，却拥有数千万美元的财富。
That's something that Elon Musk claimed without presenting any evidence at all in an Oval Office press event, where he also suggested that Social Security may be sending out checks to people 150 years old-- also without evidence, seems to be flatly untrue.
那是埃隆·马斯克在白宫新闻发布会上毫无证据地声称的，在那里他还暗示社会保障局可能正在向150岁的人发送支票——同样没有证据，看起来完全是不真实的。
Masha says these kind of lies, these bully lies, are different from the kind of lies that we've been used to in American politics for most of our history, where the two sides argue back and forth, present evidence, try to convince each other-- or try to convince voters, at least.
Masha说这种谎言，这些霸凌谎言，与我们历史上美国政治中习以为常的谎言不同，在那里，双方进行辩论，出示证据，试图说服对方——或者至少试图说服选民。
The bully lie is different. It doesn't try to convince you. It doesn't present evidence. It just tells you to pick a side. So when the president said that diversity programs caused the plane crash over the Potomac, when he called the president of Ukraine a dictator without elections, he didn't lay out a set of facts to make his case. He wasn't interested in rebuttal.
霸凌谎言则不同。它不试图说服你。它不提供证据。它只是告诉你选边站。所以当总统说多元化项目导致飞机在波托马克河坠毁时，当他称乌克兰总统为没有选举的独裁者时，他并没有摆出一系列事实来支持他的主张。他不关心反驳。
When he does this kind of thing, Masha writes, he's "asserting control over reality itself" and splitting the country into those who agree to live in his reality and those who resist and become his enemies by insisting on facts.
当他做这种事时，Masha写道，他是在“宣示对现实本身的控制”，并将国家分裂成那些同意生活在他现实中的人，以及那些坚持事实而成为他敌人的抵抗者。
I don't know if it's worth complicating this analysis with this example, but I was actually able to think of one instance of the Democrats doing the kind of bully lie that Masha writes about, and it's a big one that we all just lived through. It seemed like it was done more out of desperation than anything else and not part of a daily pattern of making false claims with no facts behind them. The thing I'm talking about is Joe Biden and his advisors concealing how he had aged in office. I talked to Masha about this.
我不知道用这个例子来使分析复杂化是否值得，但我确实想到了一个民主党人使用Masha所写的那种霸凌谎言的例子，这是一个我们都经历过的重大事件。它看起来更像是出于绝望，而不是每天在没有事实支持的情况下发表虚假声明的模式的一部分。我说的是乔·拜登和他的顾问们隐瞒他任期内的衰老程度。我和Masha谈过这件事。
That basically was making everybody in the country choose, either you accept what we're telling you about Biden or you're against us.
那基本上是在让全国每个人选择，要么你接受我们关于拜登的说法，要么你就是站在我们对立面。
Oh, absolutely. I mean, I wrote a piece about it at The Times saying that it was totally Trumpian behavior. I did not win any friends with that piece, but that's what it felt like because we could see it. We could see it at the debate. And then there were all these people around Biden who were saying, don't believe your lying eyes. He is in control. He is running the country. It had that feel of the bully lie.
噢，绝对。我的意思是，我在《泰晤士报》上写了一篇文章，说那是完全的特朗普式行为。我没因为那篇文章赢得什么友谊，但那种感觉就是如此，因为我们能看到。我们可以在辩论中看到它。然后拜登周围有很多人在说，别相信你们受骗的眼睛。他在掌控。他在治理国家。它确实有霸凌谎言的感觉。
The reason Masha is so aware of what that feels like is that they grew up in Russia, left, came back, then fled when it became impossible for them to keep living there under Vladimir Putin. Masha says the bully lie is significant because it's not a traditional part of American politics, but it is a very standard tactic of authoritarian leaders around the world and in history.
Masha之所以对那种感觉如此敏锐，是因为他们是在俄罗斯长大的，离开后又回去，然后在弗拉基米尔·普京领导下无法继续生活时逃离了。Masha说霸凌谎言意义重大，因为它不是美国政治的传统部分，但它是世界各地和历史上威权领导人的一个非常标准的策略。
Masha has actually written and reported a ton about this. They wrote a book about Putin and another one about Russia's recent turn to totalitarianism. And authoritarian government, just to remind you, is basically a government run by one person, a strongman leader, who holds all the power, which, of course, is different from our system of checks and balances.
Masha确实写过并报道过很多关于这个的内容。他们写了一本关于普京的书，还有一本关于俄罗斯最近转向极权主义的书。威权政府，提醒一下，基本上是由一个人管理的政府，一个强人领导，掌握着所有权力，这当然与我们的制衡体系不同。
Masha wrote about the bully lie in their book about Donald Trump's first term. The book is called Surviving Autocracy. That's what I asked them to read from a little earlier. In that book, Masha argues that Donald Trump does lots of things that we normally see from authoritarian leaders, not just the bully lies.
Masha在他们关于唐纳德·特朗普第一任期的书中写到了霸凌谎言。那本书叫《在专制中幸存》。那就是我请他们刚才朗读的内容。在那本书中，Masha认为唐纳德·特朗普做了很多我们通常在威权领导人身上看到的行为，而不仅仅是霸凌谎言。
And I think it's worth talking about it for a little bit here. I found it eye-opening to see it laid out point by point. And I just want to say, if you like the president and you think talking about him this way is just way, way out of line, just stay with me. We talked about that.
我认为在这里谈论它一段时间是值得的。我发现把它一点一点地列出来让我大开眼界。我只想说，如果你喜欢总统，并且认为这样谈论他简直是大错特错，请继续听下去。我们谈过那个问题。
I feel very aware that people who like the president may hear you say the word "autocrat" and just think it's nuts, and you're just looking for any alarmist thing you can say to make him look bad. Can I ask you to make your case for a skeptical listener?
我非常清楚，喜欢总统的人听到你用“独裁者”这个词，可能会觉得这是疯了，你只是在寻找任何你能说出的危言耸听的言论来让他看起来很糟糕。我能请你为持怀疑态度的听众辩护一下吗？
What are the things that Donald Trump does that usually we see from autocrats and not from just regular American politicians who might lie and do whatever it is that they do? What are the things that he's doing that are more typical for autocrats?
唐纳德·特朗普做了哪些我们通常在独裁者身上看到，而不是在可能会撒谎并做他们所做之事的普通美国政客身上看到的行为？他正在做哪些更典型的独裁者行为？
Well, at this point, there is every indication-- and by every indication, I mean all the things that he constantly says-- that he actually thinks that that's how government should work. It should be one person making decisions.
嗯，在这一点上，所有迹象都表明——我所说的所有迹象，是指他不断说的所有话——他实际上认为政府就应该是这样运作的。应该由一个人来做决定。
Right. You're making me think of him deciding to weigh in on and ban congestion pricing in New York City from the White House--
对。你让我想起他在白宫决定插手并禁止纽约市的交通拥堵定价——
Exactly.
完全正确。
--and saying, I'm the king. Long live the king.
——并说，我是国王。国王万岁。
Right.
对。
Yeah.
是啊。
Or calling out the governor of Maine for, I guess, in his opinion, not following his executive order on disallowing transgender athletes in sports, with the governor responding that the state of Maine has its own laws, and him basically saying-- I can't remember the exact quote, but basically saying, I'm in charge here, and we'll see who wins.
或者点名批评缅因州州长，我想，在他看来，没有遵守他关于禁止跨性别运动员参加体育运动的行政命令，而州长回应称缅因州有自己的法律，而他基本上说——我记不清确切的引述，但基本上是说，这里我说了算，我们走着瞧。
That is actually almost the definition of an autocrat-- acting like you have ultimate and unchecked power. And there are other specific things, Masha says, that Donald Trump has done in the last few weeks that are standard moves for an autocrat. Number one, punishing press outlets who don't do what he says. Trump kicked the Associated Press from covering him in the Oval Office, on Air Force 1, and at major events after they refused to call the Gulf of Mexico, the Gulf of America like he wants.
这实际上几乎就是独裁者的定义——表现得好像你拥有最终且不受制约的权力。还有其他具体的事情，Masha说，唐纳德·特朗普在过去几周所做的，是独裁者的标准动作。第一，惩罚那些不服从他的媒体。特朗普在美联社拒绝称墨西哥湾为他想要的“美国湾”后，禁止他们报道他在白宫、空军一号和重大活动的消息。
Autocrats go after their enemies. Donald Trump has been going after so many enemies publicly. Former aides. He fired Justice Department officials who prosecuted cases against him. And this week, even went after the law firm that is giving advice to one of those officials, taking away their security clearances which will make defending that official harder. That is very autocratic leader. And then there's Donald Trump's basic campaign message, make America great again.
独裁者会打击他们的敌人。唐纳德·特朗普一直在公开打击这么多敌人。前助手。他解雇了起诉他的司法部官员。本周，甚至打击了为这些官员之一提供建议的律师事务所，取消了他们的安全许可，这将使这些官员的辩护更加困难。那是典型的独裁领导人。还有唐纳德·特朗普竞选的基本口号，让美国再次伟大。
A better future that's basically the past is a common trait to all modern autocrats. And then in the 20th century, we also had some futuristic autocrats. The Soviet totalitarianism was probably the most vivid example. But all the autocrats have come to power in the world in the last 15 or so years on this wave of resurgent autocracies, they're all past oriented.
一个本质上是过去的更美好的未来是所有现代独裁者的共同特征。在20世纪，我们也有一些未来主义的独裁者。苏联的极权主义可能是最生动的例子。但在过去15年左右在全球掌权的独裁者，他们都在这股重生的专制主义浪潮中，他们都面向过去。
They're saying, we had a glorious past, and we've got to go back to it.
他们说，我们有辉煌的过去，我们必须回到那个过去。
Yeah, it's make whatever country great again. And it's always an imaginary past, when you felt comfortable, when you didn't have these anxieties, when your children were just like you, when men were men and women were women, and everyone spoke the same language as you do.
是的，就是让某个国家再次伟大。而且那总是一个想象中的过去，当你感到舒适的时候，当你没有这些焦虑的时候，当你的孩子和你一样的时候，当男人是男人，女人是女人，当每个人说的语言都和你一样的时候。
Yeah. Yeah. What do you make of all the things that Trump has been saying lately about taking over Greenland and the Panama Canal and Gaza?
是啊。是啊。你如何看待特朗普最近说的关于接管格陵兰岛、巴拿马运河和加沙的所有话？
I think a few things are happening there, and I think they're pretty scary. I think the first time he mentioned Greenland, which was during his first term, it was probably at a moment's inspiration. He probably meant nothing by it.
我想那里正在发生一些事情，而且我觉得它们相当可怕。他第一次提到格陵兰岛时，那是在他的第一任期内，那可能是一时的灵感。他可能并没有什么恶意。
Just like out loud trolling or say a noisy thing, it'll get a headline, and who cares?
就像大声引战，或者说些嘈杂的事情，它会上头条，谁在乎呢？
Exactly, which is very much his--
完全正确，这非常符合他的——
What he does all the time.
他一直在做的事。
Yeah. One thing about Trump, though, is that he's very sensitive to being heard. Greenland was heard, and because Greenland was heard, it became a kind of an idée fixe. And so now, in his second term, he's bringing up Greenland again. I think it's a whole other story. It's no longer an absurd, trolling kind of meme thing. It's beginning to approach policy.
是啊。然而，关于特朗普的一点是，他对是否被听到非常敏感。格陵兰岛被听到了，正因为格陵兰岛被听到了，它变成了一种“固定观念”。所以现在，在他的第二任期，他再次提到了格陵兰岛。我认为那是另一个故事。它不再是一个荒谬的、引战的模因式的东西。它开始接近政策了。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I think that the way that he is also throwing around the Panama Canal and the Gulf of America, of course, he's doing this because totalitarian leaders have to promise expansion. That's like--
而且我认为他到处谈论巴拿马运河和美国湾的方式，当然，他这样做是因为极权领导人必须承诺扩张。这就像——
Why?
为什么？
It's an axiom.
这是一种公理。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What are you saying? Like, they have a rule book that they have to follow?
你在说什么？就像他们有一本必须遵守的规则书？
Absolutely. I'm actually half serious. Like that--
绝对。我其实有一半是认真的。就像——
You are serious. There are certain things that they do. Like, for example, they pick some group in society to be the, like, these are the people who we hate, who are ruining things for the rest of us. That's one thing they do.
你是认真的。他们确实做某些事情。比如，他们会在社会中挑选某些群体作为，比如，这就是我们憎恨的人，是他们毁了其他人的生活。这是他们做的一件事。
Exactly.
完全正确。
And then another thing is that they call to some sort of golden age.
然后另一件事是他们呼唤某种黄金时代。
Yeah, that they're going to recreate in the future.
是的，他们将来会重建那个时代。
And then you're saying another one is just we're going to expand?
然后你说另一件事就是我们将会扩张？
Yeah. Yeah, we're going to take over other lands. And what it is, I think it's a promise of greatness. It's a trade-off. Generally speaking, autocratic regimes don't, in the long run, prove economically beneficial--
是的。是的，我们要接管其他土地。而且我认为这是一种伟大的承诺。这是一种权衡。一般来说，专制政权从长远来看，并不能证明在经济上是有益的——
To the population.
对民众来说。
--to the population. Right, they're usually economically beneficial to the actual autocrat and his cohort. And you will not necessarily be personally better off. So what is he going to actually give them? What he's going to give them is a sense of belonging to something greater.
——对民众来说。对，它们通常对真正的独裁者和他的帮派有经济效益。而且你未必会亲自过得更好。那么他实际上要给他们什么呢？他要给他们的是一种属于更伟大事业的归属感。
And the something greater is a country that's expanding its borders?
而那个更伟大的事业就是一个正在扩张边界的国家？
Yeah, yeah, the greatest country in the world that is expanding its borders.
是啊，是啊，世界上最伟大的正在扩张边界的国家。
OK, so obviously, nobody knows what's coming next. But if you see Trump as a kind of autocratic ruler and you worry about him taking more power in that way, what are the things you'd be looking for next? Like, what are the markers of it going further?
好的，所以很显然，没人知道接下来会发生什么。但如果你把特朗普看作是一种独裁统治者，并且你担心他以那种方式夺取更多权力，接下来你会寻找哪些迹象？比如，有什么进一步的迹象？
Well, the problem is that we're always looking for that one thing, or there's three things. And now once we check them off, we're living in an autocracy. The problem is that it's actually always a gradual process, and it's happening much faster here than it's happened in any country that I'm familiar with.
嗯，问题在于我们总是在寻找那一件事情，或者三件事。一旦我们勾选了它们，我们就生活在独裁统治中。问题在于它实际上总是一个渐进的过程，而且在这里发生的速度比我熟悉的任何国家都要快。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes. [CLEARS THROAT] I mean, it took Putin quite a long time to establish actual authoritarian rule, and then another number of years to turn that regime into a totalitarian one. The way that Trump is taking a sledgehammer to government is certainly unprecedented in my memory. But I think the things that we have to look for, some of them, you can sort of measure, like when they start consistently ignoring court decisions that are not favorable to them.
是的。[清嗓子] 我的意思是，普京花了很长时间才建立真正的威权统治，然后又花了几年时间才把那个政权变成极权政权。特朗普用大锤破坏政府的方式，在我记忆中无疑是史无前例的。但我认为我们必须寻找的东西，其中一些，你可以衡量，比如当他们开始持续无视对他们不利的法院判决时。
Yeah.
对。
So far, they've ignored some, it seems like. But it doesn't look like it's consistent. But at some point, I would expect them-- or let's say, I will fear that they will say these court decisions that go against the government are illegitimate. So that will be a huge marker.
到目前为止，他们无视了一些，似乎是这样。但这看起来并不一致。但在某个时刻，我会预期他们——或者说，我会担心他们会说这些违背政府的法院判决是非法的。那将是一个巨大的标志。
But then there are softer things like shifting consensus. And I think it's already happening. That's one way of understanding what people have also been calling the obeying in advance that we have seen all over the place. The most vivid example of it is by far not the only one, right, but it's Mark Zuckerberg's little address when he announced that they were not going to have fact-checking on Facebook anymore. He kept saying, things have changed. This is a new moment. We're going to move our operations to Texas because that's the new moment we're living in.
但还有更柔和的东西，比如共识的转变。我认为这已经发生了。这是理解人们一直所说的我们在各处看到的“预先服从”的一种方式。其中最生动的例子绝非唯一，对吧，但那是马克·扎克伯格在宣布他们不再对Facebook进行事实核查时发表的小演讲。他一直在说，事情变了。这是一个新的时刻。我们将把我们的业务转移到德克萨斯州，因为那是我们生活的新时刻。
And all of these things are ways of saying, look, I'm fully accepting that Trump has created a new reality. And I'm going to take all my things and move into that reality with him and live there with him. And anybody who refuses to do that, they're going to be left out in the cold.
而所有这些都是在说，看，我完全接受特朗普创造了一个新的现实。我要带着我所有的东西搬进那个现实，和他住在一起。任何拒绝那样做的人，他们都将被冷落。
Masha Gessen. Their book about Donald Trump and his autocratic tendencies is called Surviving Autocracy. These days, they're an opinion columnist at The New York Times.
Masha Gessen。他们关于唐纳德·特朗普及其专制倾向的书叫《在专制中幸存》。这些天，他们是《纽约时报》的观点专栏作家。
They recently wrote in The Times-- "Life under autocracy can be terrifying, as it already is in the United States for immigrants and trans people. But those of us with experience can tell you, most of the time, for most people, it's not frightening. It is stultifying. It's boring. It feels like trying to see and breathe underwater because you're submerged in bad ideas, being discussed badly, being reflected in bad journalism, and eventually, in bad literature and bad movies."
他们最近在《泰晤士报》写道：“专制下的生活可能是可怕的，对于美国的移民和跨性别者来说，情况已经如此了。但我们中那些有经验的人可以告诉你，大多数时候，对于大多数人来说，它并不令人恐惧。它是令人窒息的。它很无聊。感觉就像试图在水下看和呼吸，因为你沉浸在糟糕的想法中，被糟糕地讨论，在糟糕的新闻报道中反映出来，最终，在糟糕的文学和糟糕的电影中。”
Just this week, lawyers nominated for top positions in the Justice Department, including solicitor general, were asked if the president could ignore or disobey a court order. And they hedged. They did not say that he should obey. Vice President Vance said earlier this month that judges should not be allowed to control what the president does.
就在本周，被提名为司法部高级职位的律师，包括副总检察长，被问及总统是否可以无视或违抗法院命令。他们闪烁其词。他们没有说他应该服从。副总统万斯本月初表示，不应该允许法官控制总统的行为。
Act Three, "In Defense of Unnecessary Lies." Well, it's been nearly a whole hour talking about far-fetched lies that do not seem to make the world a better place at all. Our tone, I'll admit, has been skeptical, sometimes incredulous. In this act, we turn that around. I present one of our coworkers here at the radio show, Ike Sriskandaraja.
第三幕，“为不必要的谎言辩护”。嗯，花了一个小时谈论那些似乎根本没让世界变得更美好的离奇谎言。我承认，我们的基调一直持怀疑态度，有时甚至是难以置信。在这一幕中，我们反其道而行之。我隆重介绍我们广播节目的同事之一，Ike Sriskandaraja。
Sometimes in my own life, just for fun, I'll make up something and tell people. Here's one from years ago. You remember Karl Rove, the guy who helped get George W. Bush elected to be governor and then president? I told my friend Charles that this man, well into his 60s, was really only 36. He just looked old.
有时候在我自己的生活中，仅仅为了好玩，我会编造一些事情告诉别人。这里有一个几年前的故事。你记得Karl Rove吗，那个帮助乔治·W·布什当选州长然后成为总统的家伙？我告诉我的朋友Charles，这个年过60的人，其实只有36岁。他只是看起来老。
I guess I liked the world where things aren't quite as they appear, and the people running the show are more like children in grown-up suits. And Charles, he went with it, so hard that years later, he came back and told me he'd told dozens of people before catching the lie, which, to be honest, made me feel great and enjoy the lie even more that strangers I never met got to step into this funny little warped reality.
我想我喜欢那个事情并非看起来那样，而掌权者更像是穿大号西装的孩子们的世界。而Charles，他深信不疑，以至于几年后，他回来告诉我，在识破那个谎言之前，他已经告诉了十几个人，说实话，这让我感觉很棒，也更享受这个谎言，因为我从未见过的陌生人竟然能走进这个有趣的小扭曲现实。
But sometimes these lies of amusement don't work out so well. Like, for instance, when my dad came to visit me years ago and was staying over in my small apartment, he noticed a diploma on my desk ordaining me as a minister.
但有时这些为了娱乐的谎言效果并不好。比如，当我父亲几年前来看我，住在我狭窄的公寓里时，他注意到我桌上有一份任命我为牧师的文凭。
I still remember that very well. It was a certificate, some kind of a certification.
我至今仍记得非常清楚。那是一份证书，某种认证。
My dad.
我父亲。
My first impression was you had changed your religion from Hinduism to some other unknown cult.
我的第一印象是你把宗教从印度教改成了某个未知的邪教。
It would have been easy to correct this misunderstanding and tell my dad the real story-- that my friends had asked me to officiate their wedding. And to legally marry them, I had to get ordained in an online church. It just seemed funnier to go along with the story that I was now a minister in a Christian cult.
纠正这个误解并告诉父亲真实的故事——我的朋友请我主持他们的婚礼。为了合法地结婚，我必须在网上教堂受戒——本来很容易。只是继续那个我现在是基督教邪教牧师的故事似乎更有趣。
It came as a surprise to me because for so many generations, we have been following this religion. So I was a little disappointed. But things happen.
这让我很惊讶，因为这么多代以来，我们一直遵循这种宗教。所以我有点失望。但事情发生了。
As soon as he came home, he told me.
他一到家，就告诉我了。
My mom.
我母亲。
I thought it was odd because you would have told me about it if you were doing something like this. So it came as a huge surprise to me, too.
我觉得这很奇怪，因为如果你做了这样的事，你肯定会告诉我的。所以这对我来说也感到非常惊讶。
While my dad met my fake conversion story with resigned disappointment and no follow-up questions, my mom just called me.
当我爸用无奈的失望和没有后续问题来回应我的虚假皈依故事时，我妈直接打电话给我。
So when we spoke the next time, I brought it up, and I asked you about it. Then you started laughing. Then I knew it was just a joke. Then I had to tell Dad.
所以当我们下次交谈时，我提到了这件事，我问了你。然后你开始大笑。那时我知道那只是个玩笑。然后我不得不告诉爸爸。
I was relieved. I didn't have to think about it anymore.
我松了一口气。我再也不用去想它了。
Did you think it was a good joke?
你认为这是一个好玩笑吗？
Yes. It's an excellent joke.
是的。这是一个出色的玩笑。
Is that a lie?
那是一个谎言吗？
It's a white lie.
那是一个善意的谎言。
Honestly, this all surprised me that my dad couldn't tell I was joking, mostly because I learned this type of joke from him.
老实说，这一切让我很惊讶，我父亲竟然没看出来我在开玩笑，主要是因为我这种类型的玩笑是从他那里学的。
What did you say?
你说什么？
I've just been doing your joke, the joke you make all the time where you lie about something.
我只是在模仿你的玩笑，就是你经常撒谎说某事的那个玩笑。
I didn't know that. [LAUGHS]
我不知道这一点。[笑]
He does lie a lot, yes.
他确实经常撒谎，是的。
My dad tells people he came to America by going through a tunnel under the wall. Other times, it's a boat. When I was a kid, he told me the stretch marks on his shoulders were from a fight he had with a tiger. I told everybody.
我父亲告诉别人他是通过墙下的隧道来到美国的。有时，它是条船。当我还是个孩子的时候，他告诉我他肩膀上的妊娠纹是他和一只老虎打架留下的。我告诉了所有人。
But my favorite lie he told happened during a math class my dad used to teach at Madison Area Technical College. My good friend Buskus was taking it, and I decided to go with him. Now, before the lesson started, my dad introduced me to the class.
但我最喜欢他讲的一个谎言发生在我父亲过去在麦迪逊地区技术学院教的一门数学课期间。我的好朋友Buskus正在上那门课，我决定和他一起去。现在，在课程开始前，我父亲把我介绍给了班级。
I do remember that. I introduced you as a foreign exchange student from Nicaragua. Although you didn't look like a Nicaraguan.
我确实记得那个。我把你介绍成来自尼加拉瓜的外国交换生。尽管你看起来不像尼加拉瓜人。
Why did you say that?
你为什么那么说？
Because we had students from Central American countries. I wanted to make use of that and came up with this idea.
因为我们有来自中美洲国家的学生。我想利用这一点，想出了这个主意。
Well, I understand why it's plausible, but why did you even tell a lie about where your son was from, instead of saying, my son is here?
嗯，我明白为什么它听起来可信，但你为什么要撒谎说你儿子来自哪里，而不是说，我儿子在这里？
I just wanted to play a practical joke with my students. It is also for Buskus, who knows the real story and who started laughing.
我只是想和我的学生开个恶作剧。这也为了Buskus，他知道真实的故事，并开始大笑。
My dad and my friend Buskus started laughing so hard they were wiping tears from their eyes. The rest of the class seemed confused why their teacher was misidentifying a new South Asian student as being from Central America. It was very funny, especially for those of us who have to field a lot of those "Where are you from originally?" types of questions.
我父亲和我的朋友Buskus笑得眼泪都出来了。班上其他人似乎很困惑，为什么他们的老师把一个南亚新学生错误地鉴定为来自中美洲。这非常有趣，特别是对于我们这些经常要面对“你最初来自哪里？”这类问题的人来说。
Anyone carefully observing my dad might notice he has a tell-- quick eyebrow raise and a big grin. I have the same tell, and people close to me know it. But apparently, that doesn't make it any less frustrating to live with. Early in our relationship, my now-wife Emma told me it was driving her crazy. She didn't want to look over her shoulder to check for my tell or second-guess everything I was telling her.
任何仔细观察我父亲的人可能会注意到他有一个信号——快速抬眉毛和露齿大笑。我有同样的信号，亲近我的人都知道。但显然，这并没有让生活变得不那么令人沮丧。在我们恋爱初期，我现在的妻子Emma告诉我，这让她快疯了。她不想转过头去检查我的信号，也不想质疑我告诉她的每一件事。
Like, do you really want to go to an info session on a timeshare in Juarez? Or what do you mean, the president says he will raise the black flag of ISIS over the White House? She told me to stop. Neither of us remember the exact lie that drove her over the top, but she remembers the feeling very clearly.
比如，你真的想去胡亚雷斯的一个分时度假信息会吗？或者你是什么意思，总统说他会在白宫升起ISIS的黑旗？她让我停止。我们都不记得那个让我崩溃的确切谎言，但她清楚地记得那种感觉。
I wanted an actual answer about whether it was how you felt, or what you wanted to do, or where we should put the thing, or should we whatever, something kind of day to day. And the accumulation of getting not-real answers that I then had to parse and say, wait, but just what do you-- I just need you to tell me straight so we can move on from this. I think that was the thing that took me to wanting you to stop.
我想要一个关于那是否是你的真实感受的实际答案，或者你想做什么，或者我们应该把东西放在哪里，或者我们应该做什么，诸如此类日常的事情。而这种得到非真实答案的积累，我不得不去分析，说，等等，但你到底……我只是需要你直接告诉我，这样我们才能继续。我想那是让我想要你停止的事情。
Emma compared it to this thing I did when I was 26 and had just moved into my own apartment, when I used to use my kitchen drawers for non-kitchen items, which is not exactly a lie, but felt like waking up on the set of a surrealist play.
Emma把它比作我26岁刚搬进自己公寓时做的事，那时我经常把厨房抽屉用来放非厨房用品，那不完全是谎言，但感觉像是醒在了一场超现实主义戏剧的片场里。
It's just confusing. [CHUCKLES] And this was when we first started dating or maybe even before. And I was looking for something in your kitchen. You had maybe, like, two forks and two spoons. And I was probably looking for one of these forks or something. And I opened a drawer, like a logical place to have silverware, and instead found either boxers or DVDs, like Seinfeld box set. And it was funny, but it was also maddening.
这很让人困惑。[轻笑] 那是在我们刚开始约会时，甚至可能更早。我在你的厨房里找东西。你可能只有大约两个叉子和两个勺子。我可能在找这些叉子中的一个之类的东西。我打开了一个抽屉，一个放银器合乎逻辑的地方，结果却发现了拳击短裤或DVD，比如《宋飞正传》盒装版。这很有趣，但也让人发狂。
Emma didn't want to live in Wonderland. It's too crazy, too hard to find the forks. If we were going to make plans together for the rest of our lives, she wanted straight answers. So I stopped lying to her. For years, I packed this part of me away, in the dresser I ended up buying for my underwear. But now we have two kids, and I've brought lying back into our house, especially with our oldest.
Emma不想住在仙境里。那太疯狂了，太难找到叉子了。如果我们要在一起规划余生，她想要直接的答案。所以我停止了对她撒谎。多年来，我把这部分自己打包收好，放在我最后买的放内衣的梳妆台里。但现在我们有两个孩子了，我又把撒谎带回了我们的房子，特别是对于我们最大的孩子。
Just recently, like a day ago-- what did you say? You looked at his foot, and you were like-- you were like, huh, where did you get all these toes? Why do you have 10 toes? Most people only have six. And now he's four and wise to you. And he was like, what? What? He's like, you're joking.
就在最近，像一天前——你说了什么？你看着他的脚，你就像——你就像，嗯，哈，你从哪弄来这么多脚趾？为什么你有10个脚趾？大多数人只有6个。现在他四岁了，对你很了解。他当时就像，什么？什么？他就像，你在开玩笑。
Leroy gets it. So far, he hasn't asked me to stop yet. Maybe you would like to try this in your own house. In fact, maybe it's a valuable lesson for your kids. It trains them to determine fact from fiction. It seems useful in our world.
Leroy懂了。到目前为止，他还没有让我停止。也许你想在自己家里试试这个。事实上，也许这对你的孩子来说是一个有价值的教训。它训练他们区分事实和虚构。在我们的世界里，这似乎很有用。
Ike Sriskandaraja is one of the producers of our show.
Ike Sriskandaraja是我们节目的制片人之一。
By the way, his friend Charles, who Ike lied to about Karl Rove, Charles told me recently that he never thought that that was true. He lied to Ike about believing it and also about telling others, just to amuse himself.
顺便说一句，他的朋友Charles，那个被Ike骗了关于Karl Rove的人，Charles最近告诉我，他从没认为那是真的。他骗了Ike说他相信了，也骗了说他告诉了别人，只是为了逗自己玩。
Well, our program was produced today by Diane Wu. The people who put together today's show include Jendayi Bonds, Michael Comite, Angela Gervasi, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Andy Carvin, Anna Starecheski, Annika Hotta, Natasha Nelson, Ira Kraemer, Eric Garcia, and Matt Miller. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Diane Wu制作。参与制作今天节目的包括Jendayi Bonds, Michael Comite, Angela Gervasi, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala和Julie Whitaker。我们的主编是Sarah Abdurrahman。高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。执行主编是Emanuele Berry。今天特别感谢Andy Carvin, Anna Starecheski, Annika Hotta, Natasha Nelson, Ira Kraemer, Eric Garcia和Matt Miller。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
I know you. You're living your life, doing stuff. You need something to listen to. What are you going to listen to? Go to our website. You can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. That is still happening. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我认识你。你在过你的生活，做着各种事。你需要听点什么。你要听什么？去我们的网站。你可以完全免费地流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案。这仍然在发生。再说一遍，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）传送到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Have you heard he is doing a one-man show based on the children's book The Very Hungry Caterpillar? It opens this way.
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Torey Malatia先生。你听说过他正在做一个基于儿童读物《好饿的毛毛虫》的独角戏吗？它是这样开场的。
Is this thing on? Can I tell you about what I ate?
这个东西开着吗？我能告诉你我吃了什么吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。